what up guys welcome to another episode
of pearl daily on the just pearly things
YouTube channel before I start make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell like the
video on your way and also guys we are
dropping two more t-shirts so not only
can you be the ultimate alpha male and
have women come up to you left and right
um with your women shouldn't vote shirt
you also can have women tell you how
awesome your t-shirts are with this
exclusive Edition One of a Kind women
shouldn't drive shirts and on top of
that we also have repeal the 19th so if
you guys want to get yourself a t-shirt
the link is in the description that's
the audacity Network dot store that's
the audacity Network dot store we have a
couple of different stories today and
what I like about this weekend stories
is it really just shows you know I try
to paint a picture of what is going on
in society and I'll tell you guys
something that irritates me a little bit
is when people come in and say red
pillars are doomsdayers I say that red
pillars live in reality and
unfortunately we have a lot of people
that are trying to sell you a dream and
I just can't do that do you know how
easy it would be for me to sell the
future is so bright and amazing but the
truth of the matter is birth rates are
dropping promiscuity is on the rise I
don't see there being less only fans
models in 10 20 years and I really wish
I could say that I predict something
different but I mean when you have the
big Banks like Morgan Stanley all
predicting that most women are going to
be single and childless and half the
people that get married are going to get
divorced that's the majority not having
a happy ending
um you know and I could sit here and
sell you a dream
and I would but I would then that would
make me someone that just tells you what
you want to hear and that sorry
um and the truth of the matter is we're
in a post-marriage world and the
marriage we see today isn't marriage so
um I'm gonna give you guys an example so
what What is marriage marriage is two
virgins coming together they typically
marry young and when we think of a
traditional
pure marriage there are two virgins they
come together Young
um ideally the the man works his way up
to protect and provide the woman takes
care of the home she has wife skills and
the issue is we really have three
generations of zero wives
um now I know what you're thinking
there's always exceptions but it doesn't
make the rule and when I interview
people I I categorize people in four
different groups so we have the 80 to
100 year olds which I really see as the
last generation of wives the women 80
plus
um the majority believed in obeying
their husband
um they stayed home they took care of
the children they had traditional skills
and their daughters which are the 60 to
80 year olds
typically
um adopted a very fearful mindset this
is when the propaganda really really
took off that generation so they while
they did they were taught to be wives
they had traditional skills they taught
their daughters wrong and they told
their daughters to focus on themselves
focus on their careers always have a
backup plan right and that typically
like what is true femininity when you
think about it
um do you think the farmers of times
past were really worried about I don't
know makeup hair
I mean like the elite women were but the
average peasant's wife no guys no and
let's stop selling these dreams to
average women that were the Queens we're
not the Queens most of us are just lowly
peasants wives yes ladies yes so okay so
that generation you see a loss of skills
this is where you see the women that
really don't know how to do anything a
lot of very lazy entitled spoiled women
because the media is telling us we're
amazing all the time social media is
telling us we're amazing our husbands
are told they can't tell us the truth
because happy wife happy life so the 40
to 40 to 60 roughly year olds are the
first generation of what I would say
shitty wives a lot of these women
prioritize themselves first a lot had
nannies they went to school they weren't
at home
um it was a me me me generation
um and that birth of my generation the
generation of women so bad that we're
not making it down the aisle
um we have more only fans models than
teachers
we have zero wife skills we just thought
you know and some of us are taking
initiative to learn but uh overall a lot
of us you know
there's a lot of craziness that the men
have to deal with now this brings me to
the Dylan danis and Logan Paul fight so
as you guys know where you may not know
Dylan danis and Logan Paul
um have a boxing match coming up in
mid-october and coming up to this fight
Dylan danis has just a known like trash
talker and I think that's why uh Logan
Paul picked him but the issue was it
kind of blew up in Logan's face a little
bit where you know he's really getting
humiliated for everyone to see because
Dylan is tweeting so many pictures of
Logan's fiance with all of her exes and
you know I was thinking about how the
generation of shitty wives the 40 to 60
year old women they would go to college
they'd have maybe crazy high school
years but then they'd get married in
their early 20s so what they did was
limited but in all honesty if things
were being recorded back then do you
think Logan's the only guy that's in
this position
I mean a lot of men just aren't aware of
what they you know married a lot I mean
Nina's women like Nina get married every
day the difference was it was documented
for her
um and you know this has a lot of
repercussions in society you know
um most women when we go back to the
traditional marriage which is being a
virgin it doesn't really exist anymore
we're really in a post-marriage society
with a lot of people just playing
pretend and calling it marriage but
they're not religious most people
they're not virgins most people
um and we're really again post-marriage
world we just it's a lot of playing
pretend so what's going on this week is
Nina has now filed a restraining order
against Dylan danis and allegedly Dylan
has been obtaining these photos through
a hacked Snapchat and apparently they
were hacking her phone so if that is
true you know obviously that's illegal
so you can't do that Dylan is arguing
that all of the stuff he's posting was
public knowledge and on the internet so
I I don't know it's kind of he said she
said at this point but Dylan has tamed
it down a little bit I haven't seen any
crazy pictures of Nina
um this crazy picture bomb that he was
gonna post hasn't been posted so I guess
we'll see
um now Logan is posting a video with
Nina
um
babe I'm hot
[Music]
all right do you have a feather in your
hair use your muscles
I don't care do you want to slushie or
not
all right here we go okay let's go yay
is my feather gone yes
oh she's so stressed
oh you gotta have a cup of salt water
should we turn it on oh hey
exciting
let me just wait
[Music]
wow it's working oh
[Applause]
like all my friends on Facebook are like
out with their children okay you're
right okay
[Music]
wow
that's great oh that's good you know
what I think this should motivate women
to get a personal trainer because really
if you're hot enough you can overcome
anything you know what I mean I'm like
you know okay anyways
um so let's look at the comments it says
it took Logan two years to build this
relationship and Dylan nuked it in two
weeks you mean the world to me means
she's been with the whole world uh bro
just kissed the whole of Hollywood she's
so sweet I'm sure she's not been ran
through by everyone in Hollywood you
know it's unfortunate if I was Logan
honestly I would just put her out of the
Limelight like there's no reason she
needs to be in the videos
um I I mean I wouldn't advise going
through with this I think it's just
gonna come with a lot of problems but if
he wants to go through with it I really
think he's just got to take her out of
the Limelight
it because at least for the time being
now um you know Logan's trying to fire
back and we've seen Logan you know put
out some stuff but it hasn't really
stuck but now I I guess they they've
leaked a video of Dylan training so
basically saying he's gonna lose this
fight so uh Dylan says Shane Mosley was
right the Paul sends spies into camps
for any advantage because they suck but
it's okay with 20 seconds left in the
round my partner who's a 15 time
Brazilian World kickboxing champion said
let's go for it I'm not afraid to sit in
the pocket and trade blows let's see who
takes the first step back on Fight Night
honestly guys I don't know anything
about boxing is that him getting I guess
he's getting his ass kicked there so a
question
that a lot of people have is because you
know Nina's alleging that
he is getting his information by hacking
her phone that that's what's a legend
right
um so now Dylan is coming in and giving
his side of the story um to Aiden Ross
because Aiden Ross did a stream I guess
with both of them with him here's the
thing about the fight right how do you
have so much [__] ammo on this guy
like seriously
every day I wake up good morning it's
you on Twitter 50 000 likes on this
picture in two hours well they go dated
like over 200 guys but it's like how do
you where do you find this where's your
ammo
they send you the picture they send me
the pictures
I think I've responded to you right but
there's really no way yeah
[Music]
you don't think he does they're Brothers
I don't know like fake Brothers
I got a message I'm gonna say what they
say I'm gonna I'll I'll ask I'll ask
Logan striking back here he says Dylan
spending his life stalking my fiance
instead of training I I'm surprised
Logan hasn't gotten any real like dirt
on him I haven't really seen because I'm
just thinking with all of this you would
see like something crazy but you know
again this kind of shows the generation
of and guys you know as hard as I do
come in on women I I don't think it's
necessarily well it is her own fault but
okay I can't do it okay I I do have some
empathy because the culture rewards one
thing Society tells us one thing and a
lot of women didn't choose to be in
households with
weak fathers that are weak because of
the mother in that relationship Dynamic
and they didn't choose to grow up in
single mother homes I have no idea what
Nina's background is but you know a lot
of women you know women have always been
this way women have always been we would
always leave The Peasant for the king
but the difference was our parents were
supposed to keep us away from those guys
but what do they do instead they send us
to college send us to get a career
um and now we live in a more
quote-unquote egalitarian society rather
than a patriarchal society and this is
what it's produced a generation I would
argue this is the third generation of
women that don't have wife a wife
mentality or wife skills you know
there's traditionalists in any society
but you know imagine having three
generations of plumbers that where they
look like a plumber they act like a
plumber but they don't know anything
about Plumbing by the third generation
you're damn near not gonna know anything
it's going to be gone I do think you're
going to see a wave of people people
like I think there's been more people
that have joined the Amish community and
maybe returning to traditionalism but
overall society's really headed one way
and you can hope that it's gonna go the
other way but I'm not in the business of
selling dreams guys and if all these
Bankers are are literally putting their
money they don't care they're they're in
it for money on the fact that we are
going to be single and childless I I
have a hard time predicting that's not
going to happen
um and so one interesting phenomenon
that you see from higher class women is
outsourcing Parenthood
um so what you'll see is they they pay
lower class women to really do their
jobs you'll see rich women dropping off
their kids at daycare hiring nannies and
you know I'm not saying I know it's a
little bit different in 2023 because
people used to have siblings they used
to be able to like all come together but
um you know there's a lot of evidence
coming out because the generation a lot
of my generation was raised by daycare
raised by nannies and there's a lot of
information coming out that saying that
that really hurts a kid's attachment
style so essentially with that when the
kid doesn't have a primary mother
caretaker that they have a hard time
attaching to someone else later and you
know that kind of matches with with what
we see in society you know a lot of
women and men both
aren't forming relationships so there is
a clip of a woman dropping off her
two-month-old baby at daycare let's pull
it
still not too late you can turn around
[Music]
foreign
ER Rose says the daycare I worked at
took babies in at six weeks old it's
been normalized for parents to not raise
their children they go from daycare to
preschool to kindergarten and on through
high school this is true you know we're
in a society where the kids are more
influenced by the state and their friend
group and their own parents
how on Earth do we raise kids with
Traditional Values If the parents are
not there to teach them
um and and you could tell the woman it
doesn't feel right she knows it's wrong
and it's like why do women they go and
make thirty five thousand dollars a year
and spend half of it on their kids like
you would think they could just go down
and lifestyle but you know we have this
Society that's keeping up with the Jones
we all need the new hairstyle the new
makeup the new clothes the getting our
nails done
um when really we could just cut down on
expenses and raise our kids
um and there's a whole generation of
women that have no idea how to raise
children
none again Guys these are skills they
have been lost and it isn't uncommon for
societies to lose knowledge
after a couple Generations we live off
of the government so much that it's
really dumbed us down we don't know how
to do anything and you see these women
that are wives they're mothers and they
really shouldn't be and I saw another
example of this on on Twitter honestly
with a mother teaching her daughter to
say that her ex graped her
man that [__] with you Rika he's mean
and you don't like him did I do that you
don't [__] with him did I do that do you
hear me he touched you
yes he did
yeah so
he got you on camera what this is a man
that [__] with you Rika he's mean and
you don't like him did I do that you
don't [__] with him did I do that do you
hear me he touched you
yes he did and this is what we don't
talk about again women and guys I'm I'm
saying this to help you understand it
women we're emotions first we're logic
second we don't think about consequences
we don't think about anyone else we just
process everything through us so what
she's doing is she's so pissed she's so
mad she she'll go to any lengths
to really destroy this man and this is
so common I've seen videos of of men
getting
beat up and killed by other men because
a woman told a story
you know and I I think the men and
women's lives really should question
them they really need to see evidence
before they just believe a chick you
know a woman can be good in your eyes
and seem all right in your eyes and
maybe in your life she's nice to you but
that doesn't mean she's trustworthy and
most women aren't credible there's a
reason why in religions like Islam they
have two women Witnesses because they
know I don't even think we fully see
reality a lot of times when we have
these emotions and that's at least once
a month
um and the problem is women like her
have had no consequence for anything
we've never seen women get consequences
so we don't think twice before doing
this stuff
and this is why I would argue you know
men raise better children so we really
need to default custody to the men I
don't understand why women get custody
when we we see women are typically chaos
men are typically more order
um so why do we trust women to raise the
kids when really the men should be
default especially when the women are
the ones leaving
so and and you see this trend of a lack
of consequences in society and what that
leads to for women so I'm going to give
you guys an example
um the woman that I covered last episode
that had a brick thrown at her face
right so and I I got some pushback I saw
the other day on this so essentially
this woman came out and said that men
were not protecting her and that she got
this brick thrown at her face and the
the men were wrong like why wouldn't
they protect her and this man
um didn't she didn't give him her number
and that's why he did it and then you
know I covered it and we see more
evidence come forward of
this woman having a history of
instigating stuff you know she was
walking around hitting white people
for no reason she was out twerking on
the streets she's a single mother she's
on drugs like guys this stuff is
supposed to come into account when
assessing The credibility of a witness
yes it matters no it's not just about
that specific instance we are building a
character a reputation and looking at
her character to see is this a credible
a credible person so not only did
everybody give her attention and
sympathy she raised 42 000
from people probably women were idiots
um you know to fix her face or whatever
the hell she needed it that 42 cap
and you know
um look look at look at what comes out
yo this man just hit me and my face with
a brick and all these black men just
watched and they don't give up
doesn't matter hit me it would grab the
Rock and it hit me in my face if I were
to give her my number
her friend her friend this time is
raising money on behalf of so she didn't
made forty thousand on the first one and
now they're creating another one with
the same scenario but a different person
allegedly but they saying that they're
all friends with rope a yellow brick
rotor so y'all have been full here's the
[__] GoFundMe a fourth GoFundMe that
they just put up and y'all believe that
this is real y'all really believe this
is real y'all are stupid
stupid
the first thing I thought was that it
didn't make any sense
the one where I'm from people don't pick
up bricks hitting people it
actually her saying that a man wanted
her number and she got the brick because
she didn't want to give him her number
it just wasn't adding up
acting like somebody did her something
when no one touched her at all she
literally already had her face like that
wore a mask and then took it off right
before filming this video and later on
we'll get into the account from the
nurse who claimed that she put that
stuff in her own face and had it drained
at a clinic
but she snatched the mask off and then
ran over in front of some guys acting
like somebody did something to her
immediately the men who are supposed to
be Somali men are just standing around
like what do you want me to do that's
because she ran from across the street
putting on this whole victim show it was
unbelievable but unbelievably all these
people believed her
so first of all shout out to Pink book
lessons really great YouTube channel she
does a good job of covering this type of
stuff
um yeah and I think really she broke it
down perfectly
um so not only this woman or gofundme's
she's done an incident like this before
the nurse is now saying she was lying
old friends have come out and said that
she just does stuff like this and the
guys didn't see the incident and there
wasn't any surveillance footage and this
is my thing guys we cannot just keep
coming to the aid of women because they
cry and whine this is what has gotten us
into trouble in the first place us
voting like this is what happens women
cry and we whine and we know we have
this like power over men
um you know this is clearly conscious I
don't think every time women do it it's
a conscious thing but it's it's like
these events keep popping up where women
literally make [__] up like you can't
even say this wasn't intentional or
planned
um I mean it's probably obviously poorly
like at least get an actor to hit you or
something you know what I mean like if
you're gonna commit commit you know but
you know and and this is my problem is
we we throw money at people because of
sympathy and it's just another way of
doing propaganda basically these women
playing victim and then everyone's oh no
and then the solution is throw money or
sympathy or attention Adam and boom now
we got a bunch of crazy batshit women
and I I think we just needed to start
Guy saying some general things about
female nature that are you know and it's
unfortunate because a lot of these that
I'm I bring up aren't positive
but I mean look at Society right now
like it's really crumbling because we
don't acknowledge the way women are and
I really think it does it does a
disservice on both sides because women
are never told the truth their whole
life and we're told we're so amazing and
special and everything we say is correct
and then the men are discriminated
against it's just it everything's out of
out of whack
um so
you know and one of those things is that
women shouldn't be in these hard jobs
and we have women lying about this stuff
we don't need women lying about men at
work and now we have women that they're
really they're giving them diversity
hires and it's obvious to everyone
around them that their diversity hires
because really women can't handle stress
like men can you know and a lot of
people it's so funny a lot of people
look to me as an example be like Pearl
aren't you like doing this high stress
job I'm like [__]
I talk for a living do you think that's
as hard as building a building do you
think that you I have it in me to go
build that building next door oh no
oh no no no no I'm like I talk and I
Tweet now don't get me wrong there's
some things that are stressful I am a
hard worker but to compare that to the
real dirty jobs of this Society like do
you remember the show Dirty Jobs and I
actually have an issue because a lot of
the streamers will look down on the men
that do these dirty jobs as if they are
somehow better more confident or smarter
than them you know and I think it's
really a disservice to the men that do
those jobs that allow us to do what we
do and it's also a disservice um to the
women
where we get in these jobs and think we
can do it when we we certainly cannot I
have no problem with women doing things
that we that we're good at right but the
problem is we keep pushing women into
things that we're bad at and then
wondering why we suck at everything so
I'll give you guys an example when I was
in high school
um I remember a guy
um telling me he scored much better on
the acts than one of my friends and at
the time he said she only got into that
school because she's a woman and I said
what no that like you're just bitter
whatever and I kind of wrote it off and
a couple years later I thought to myself
as he's doing a now today is doing a
much harder job than she is I think to
myself yeah she did get into that school
because she was a woman she was smart
right I wasn't gonna get in I don't want
to say the school but I'm like I they
would not have taken my application let
me tell you she's smarter than me but
the truth of the matter is men are
overlooked for jobs that they deserve
because they want to hand them to women
and as women we got to push back against
this [__] and and say that we are tired
of being pandered to because the women
that do work for these positions now it
looks like they're diversity hires and
we can't tell the difference
um so here here's an example so in
Russia there was a Russian space agency
and this surprises me from Russia has
threatened to press charges against the
NASA astronaut who claimed it drilled
two millimeter holes in a soyuz ms-09
vehicle that was docked at the
International Space Station in 2018. the
agency recently completed its
investigation into what it deems was a
sabotage citing senoria and
non-chancellor a crew member of the ISS
at the time of the end accident as the
culprit the allegations have been handed
over to a Russian law enforcement
allowing ruskahoma to announce the
possibility of criminal charges the
asvest the newspaper reported on Friday
citing sources that a non-chancellor
made the whole with the hopes of an
early return okay this is again again
because and this isn't to hate women but
it's genuinely to understand us she she
says I miss home I want to go home I
want to go home she's not thinking
logically she's not thinking of the any
of the consequences it's just the way I
feel first
and this is what she does
um you know it's funny when Matt can
make crimes a lot of the crimes are just
a little more logical I mean they're all
emotional right I mean usually it's the
sign of an emotional man but usually
it's like there's some upside like what
is the upside like there's a tremendous
downside from drilling a hole
into
this the station that you're in
there there is a tremendous downside
um the upside is okay she gets to go
home early
there's like not even K like when men
rob a bank there's an upside you know
what I mean sources told the Russian
news outlet that a non-chancellor wanted
to leave the orbiting laboratory due to
a blood clot or fight with her boyfriend
on board the ISS so however a
non-chancellor was married to Jeff
Chancellor when she was in space and the
two were still married to this day so
it's unclear who the boyfriend was as
stated by Russian insiders so again
that's female nature we just tend to
date and sleep with the Men at Work the
bosses the upper right now
I'm not saying every woman will
some women are you know have the morals
or whatever but in a society where we
really have little to no morals what's
stopping chicks it's not like we have a
religious Society
Daily Mail has reached out to NASA for
more information as yet and has yet to
receive a response according to a report
in Tass
roscom's most Insider claims there were
multiple holes drilled by someone
unfamiliar with the module design
without proper support to ensure
accurate Drilling and low gravity the
hole was spotted on August 30th 2018
after a pressure drop was identified due
to an air leak Russian cosmots quickly
pegged the hole and restored the
pressure patching it up with several
layers of exposure reslin a glue-like
substance okay after the hole was sealed
cosmonauts carried out the photo and
video surveillance of the whole using an
endoscope the Russian official in
September 2018 said that the hole
appeared to have punctured using a drill
and could have been caused deliberately
by someone on the ground Russia opened
an investigation into what caused the
hole in 2019 and shared allegations in
August that a non Chancellor made the
hole NASA responded by saying it does
not comment on medical matters but
disputed the claim describing the
astronaut as extremely well respected
and making many invaluable contributions
now again guys a lot women are master
manipulators you know again this is just
a woman nature thing it's not saying
every woman's gonna manipulate you but
it's kind of something that we just keep
in the back of our head like that just
kind of how women are uh Bill Nelson
head of NASA posted on Twitter in August
I fully support Serena
simping White Knight however the latest
development now opens the doors for
Russia's Ross camosis to press charges
against a non-chancellor NASA claimed
the astronauts on board were never in
danger of Suffocation due to the
Lifeboat spacecraft attachment to the
stallion to provide a return to Earth
later images and further investigation
revealed the hole had been made from the
inside ruling out space debris as the
cost
um Sergey Pro copayv and the other two
astronauts a non-chancellor of NASA and
Alexander jurst of European Space Agency
were on board as was detected the
allegation against a non-chancellor was
made in the article published t-a-s-s
claiming to debunk 12 things Americans
Claim about the Russian space space
agency they report it would not have
been possible for the damage to happen
on Earth as the ship would have never
passed vacuum chamber tests essential to
the flight being ready if there were any
holes in it than the pressure in the
ship would immediately drop and it would
not pass the appropriate test thus Ross
camosis immediately ruled out the
version of damage to the soyuz ms019 on
Earth tasks reported it then goes on to
discuss the mental health of a
non-chancellor suggesting she took
drastic action action to speed up her
return to Earth so yeah there you go
again it's a woman not being held
accountable if a man did this what do
you think would happen guys in general
and again this is why we just got to
take women out of these super high
stress jobs we can't do it and you know
um I'll I'll
say occasionally we have women that come
through but guys it's the exception it's
not the rule and we always always always
need to make sure I almost think women
need to pass more tests and go through
more rigorous training to make sure we
don't succumb to our biology I'm gonna
predict
guys guys and I fly a lot so I really
hope I'm not on one of these freaking
planes but I'm gonna predict that we're
gonna start seeing planes crashing
because we're they're letting women fly
these planes luckily I mean they're
mostly you know done on their own but I
I don't want to be on planes where women
are the pilots no thank you keep me off
of those I mean because again we process
everything emotions first especially
when it's high stress women cannot
handle stress like men can and you know
the other thing we want to talk about
when we comes to women's nature is
um we're just really selfish just as a
group like when we're left to our own
devices with all the choice
um when we had less choice we had like
seven kids and we have more choice we're
barely having two we don't tend to
choose others we tend to choose
ourselves unless we have good male
guidance but left your own devices uh I
just think it's the way we interpret
information we interpret everything
be like due to us like how it regards to
us not that's why you know whenever I
say you know men don't like fat chicks
and then the women will be like well I'm
not fat and I'm like I didn't say you
are
but if the shoe fits that's not my
problem
so we have a Matt Walsh video coming up
and he said it would be great if we
could go one day without a woman on
social media promoting shallowness and
selfless selfishness as a path to Joy
and fulfillment
so it seems that a lot of ladies are
getting divorced
before they turn 30 and as someone who
got married at 26
has been separated for a little over a
year
32 I have to tell you
I don't think there's anything better if
being in your 20s is the trenches there
is nothing better than being in your 30s
still being hot maybe having a little
bit of your own money figuring out what
you want to do with your life everything
and having tried that married fantasy
and realizing that it's maybe not all
it's cracked up to be and then you've
got your whole life still ahead of you
um so for all of those people who are
stressed or feeling stressed about that
about being divorced like it's a it's
it's good congratulations
congratulations all right all right I
want to point something out
what are we gonna rank Emily one to ten
I would put her as an eight or higher
look at Pearl's a nice chick today I'm
gonna I'm gonna put her in a nine in her
pink a nine yep and now you know maybe
she's an eight you know I mean that that
woman she's clearly aged well I mean who
knows tick tock's got all the filters so
you never know what the chicks look like
but you know let's just say an eight
right she is hot
and the difference is you know she's
telling these women she's selling them
what I call selling the dream
um you know divorced women don't tend to
have good outcomes they tend to get
divorced again or not married again and
if they do get married they tend to get
divorced yeah so these women they they
it tends to go downhill for them she has
sexual opportunity because she's hot but
most women are not as hot as her and the
other side of divorce is actually going
to be pretty miserable
um most women are in debt they don't
have money so this idea that oh you can
just come out of divorce with a little
money
yeah you do and let's be honest what do
we see with female pop stars a lot of
them piss away their money they don't
even keep it you know I I've spoken to
guys like that are in the music industry
like I know someone that has produced
for a lot of like top artists right and
he told me that a lot of these chicks
just you know they get famous they make
their money and they end up broke at 70.
and with roommates you know uh and
that's the future the the future of
tomorrow and again this is why like
honestly guys red pill seems like
doomsdayers but I'm telling you what is
going to happen to these retired only
fans models what is going to happen to
these single mothers they're gonna get
together and they're going to live
together and they're rather die than
live with a guy
I mean it's not like women as a whole
are good with money we make more money
we
we are in debt and then we take money
from the men and you know they'll live
off a child support until the kid's old
but then they'll still spend that money
too because women are women that's just
what we do and again guys this is just
female nature we're never happy we
always want better and
you know we tend to wreck our own homes
that's why we really can't have too much
choice
um or at least at the very least we need
to have consequences and right now
there's just no there's no social shame
there's no societal shame and
really we're rewarded we're given money
for leaving
um and I want to talk about how she also
said the marriage fantasy and she's
absolutely right again so she's part of
what I would say is my generation so the
25 to 40 year old women today I I would
say maybe I'd go a little down like
22-ish to 40 year old women where we
have been sold alive we've been lied to
none of us really have been told what
marriage is about marriage is about
something bigger than yourself you are
supposed to submit and obey your husband
it is always supposed to be about the
family is never about you your feelings
are unimportant you should not rely on
your husband to meet your quote unquote
emotional needs and you don't you're not
supposed to have all these freaking
boundaries with your husband it's your
husband you're supposed to trust your
husband with your life we are so
backwards where we will trust men to be
the father of our children the most
important job ever will trust these men
with our bodies but we won't trust them
to make decisions we won't trust them
with our money and we always need to
have a backup plan in our heads when we
trusted these men to Father our children
how crazy how backwards is that and so
really my generation brings literally
nothing to the table because of this
mentality the be happy the me me me
generation and it's because uh my
generation so I got social media when I
was like I don't know 14 13.
um it's getting younger nowadays you
know they they started to mess up she's
32 now so that's you know so she got the
social media really took off in her 20s
and then she got deluded to we all got
we all got freaking crazy and just
believed all these lies that they tell
us in the media and I really just think
social media has really messed us up
men don't get as messed up from social
media I don't know why I mean I can tell
you why women we just believe anything
so we believe that we're queens and
amazing and this is the future we could
just have these Happy Divorce parties
guys
no no this is all wrong marriage is
about the kids it is about raising the
Next Generation and honestly it's a
Sacrament with God
and that is why it is so offensive when
you see people make a mockery out of
marriage because they're because
religious people take marriage seriously
you know I know women that waited until
they waited till 25 they were virgins
until 25 and they got married so and and
that's a hard feat almost no women do
that they went to church every day they
prayed for a husband like you know and I
don't claim you know I'm Catholic I
don't claim to be like the perfect
picture of what a Catholic should be but
I I know there are priests there are
nons are people that perform these
ceremonies there are people that were
married 50 years that went through thick
and thin that never cheated that did the
right thing because they believed in the
sanctity of marriage and modern people
are ruining that and it's taking all of
religion away from society so and this
week you know
Adam 22 is showing why we need to start
shaming people that disrespect marriage
this is disrespectful so you know I
tweeted and I'd like to say adam22 I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you guys a
background on Adam so I went on Adam's
podcast about six months ago maybe eight
months ago I didn't really have a
problem with Adam I was super sick on
this interview I oh my gosh that is like
the sickest I have been in the longest
time I was so sick the whole interview I
was just trying not to die
and so it's kind of a mild interview
honestly and it was fine we did the
interview and then I I moved on whatever
and a couple months later
he calls me a misogynist and all of his
hosts are talking [__] about me and I'm
thinking Adam
I thought we were Pat and it's such a
weird phenomenon where like you'll know
someone and then they go I mean I'm like
all right whatever
fair play
fair play I'm like all right
I I see how this is so the atom 22 and
Lena [__] comes out I'm like fine
you want to call me a misogynist let's
talk about the real misogyny you pimping
out your wife
and so I actually I had this thought
yesterday where I was thinking we I
interview all these only fans models and
guys you have to understand I I do this
I I talk to them all the time even my
producers are starting to realize like
patterns with these chicks none of them
ever have a plan if they have a plan
it's like real estate or going into like
production but none of them have really
accomplished anything
and they they basically are just they
have a hard time dating they'll tell you
they have a hard time dating and even if
you survey men most would eliminate a
woman as a long-term Prospect if she's
done only fans
and so really like what what are what is
society going to do with all these old
[__]
they're not going to settle
um they're not gonna
um they're not gonna settle they're not
gonna
go down and die so what's really gonna
happen because they're not gonna get the
men that they want
um and so I tweeted and this wasn't even
about Adam anymore that's funny thing
what do we do with these only fans
[__] once they're broke [__] that no
one wants to marry in 15 years so I
tweet that right and Adam Adam comes
back at me and says no offense but you
should be more worried about nobody
wanting to marry you right now you know
um and I just thought it was so
interesting because I said your
definition of marriage is letting
another dude bang your wife on camera
people like you are ruining the sanctity
of marriage it's an insult to people
that take marriage seriously
and I really I really believe this I
really believe that true marriage is
between two virgins I believe some
non-virgins get lucky and you know
they're in a society where that stuff's
accepted but I really think it's true
marriage but now now we're getting to
the point
or [__] literal and I'm not even you
know I know sometimes I'll be like guys
two bodies [__] it's more for
definition purposes but
you know now now we're getting to the
point where literal prostitutes
are are getting rings and we all know
it's not gonna work out and he says I'm
a happily married dude with children
you're an unwed sinner with no suitors
you will die alone in a bingo hall so
you know fair enough so I just give my
take you know I didn't know marriage was
cucking out your wife at the expense of
your children if that's what marriage is
I'd rather die alone I swear to do I
would rather I would rather be by myself
with cats than do what Adam is doing
I I would rather that's what I'll pick I
I pick the cats over a dude over your
your husband the guy that's supposed to
protect you cucking you out with porn
stars really
um and and my question genuine question
why do you get married why do people
like you get married why insult
religious people by making a mockery of
the sacrament guys if I'm being honest
like I I think marriage is such a holy
sacrament that barely anybody deserves
it keyword deserves some people get it
because of God's grace but I really I
really think rarely people actually
deserve marriage and so my question and
you know the people that do get married
that have had crazy pasts they at least
put it aside and and start something new
and beautiful but what you're seeing
with with him really is making a lot
like they could have did this before
they got married but it's like then why
get married if God isn't at the center
it's it's supposed to be a religious
Sacrament with God that's that's what
marriage is and you you could see the
wording he says we got married because
we plan on spending the rest of our
lives together and you can tell how sure
he is of the relationship because it's a
plan
it's not what it's not what they're
gonna do if it offends religious people
that's a huge Plus for me so that's off
awesome to hear you know and I I have to
be honest guys like you know that would
be like me imagine me and I I don't
really know like I I don't I'm not too
familiar with the Islamic like what they
do with the mosque but I'll give you an
example right
so when I was like 18 my family we went
to uh I was like 18 19 we went to I
can't remember where I think it was like
Abu Dhabi or somewhere in the Middle
East and we all went as a family a super
fun trip and
um I remember we went into like one of
the mosques and you had to put on
um the like I don't know what they're
called but the hair covering stuff and
you know my my mom and my dad really
explained to me that you are in someone
else's like religious uh place you're in
another country you need to follow their
rules these are their rules and so you
know I so we did and there wasn't you
know a question but people like this
it's like they're playing pretend
they're pretending to be married they're
pretending to be a husband and wife but
really it's just two porn stars putting
on a show
um and I think that's offensive the same
way I think it would be really offensive
for me to go and and do some Jewish
traditions and like Islamic Traditions
um without actually walking the walk you
know again I'm not really too familiar
but it's like I'm a Catholic so I'll
give you an example from a catholic's
point of view you know we we take
communion really seriously and people
and you have to get your first communion
um
first like you have to go through that
Sacrament and I I think it's it'd be
really disrespectful for someone to be
you know claimed to be a Catholic by in
doing this this porn stuff or like you
know using that Sacrament and you know
like imagine if oh my gosh I can't even
oh this like makes me sick to think
about but role playing that in a like a
sex scene I think that's gross I think
that's wrong and I think it's it's wrong
to the people that actually take
marriage seriously
um and so I said it's actually people
like this that need to be shamed out of
marriage they ruined it for the people
that actually believe in marriage and
that's what you got a lot of fake wives
a lot of fake wives that don't believe
in submission a lot of fake wives that
Nag on their husbands constantly a lot
of fake wives that give their kids to
daycare instead of raising them a lot of
fake wives that don't cook for their
family a lot of fake wives that really
Bamboozled their husband that have these
crazy paths that they didn't tell their
husbands about and you know it's one
thing to come in with like humility
right and I and I've you know I think
the most women I wouldn't advise men to
go for women with a past pretty much
ever because we just yeah but you know
the women that do make changes and men
too right they come in with some
humility but it's like this arrogance
and this this deserving that I can't
stand I really think very few people
deserve marriage I think very few people
walk the walk to be honest in 2023 I
think have a very toxic society and it
is incredibly offensive
that we have people role-playing
marriage without submitting to their
husband without you know dressing
modestly it's like then why get married
in the first place so and I said it's
actually disgusting that you set out to
offend religious people that take
marriage seriously it's a Sacrament Adam
a promise to God and you know notice he
says we plan on spending the rest of our
lives together instead of we will he
says Pearl chooses podcasting and
tweeting over getting married and
starting a family fortunately she'll
have Candy Crush and a bunch of cats to
comfort her with old old age
So I responded I said at least I didn't
choose porn over marriage at a family
like your wife I mean that's the choice
is that different and you know what the
funny thing is I used to work in
Corporate America do you know what my
life was like before this I have a
hundred percent control over my schedule
I get to work from home before I worked
in you know how miserable that was
copier sales
oh my gosh this is amazing I'm so tired
of podcasters acting like we're just
these godsends because we talk for a
living we talk and tweet and that's why
I say you know podcasting really is easy
influencers just like to cry and whine
about it the worst part about adam22 is
what he promotes is actually going to
leave these women miserable you know I
interview only fans models all the time
they have zero savings zero plans and
zero dating prospects if this [__] goes
south they have no backup plan and Adam
will sell them a dream that women
like his wife you know can get a happy
outcome and some will I'm not even
saying none will but a lot won't and for
every one that does there's ten that
don't and as women we always think we're
special in the exception and the truth
is most of us are average and normal
what do you what do you think a man has
to make to afford a housewife
let's say let's say let's just go
that's a Range Rover She's Not Just
the norm I'm definitely
[Music]
all right so 100K 100K so what percent
of guys do you think make 100k
right
10 to 15 yeah you're right roughly I
don't remember these like 10 yeah five
percent or something like that I I don't
know 100K here is higher I'm thinking
U.S terms but it's probably like eight
but okay close enough right so what age
do you think that men make that much
money oh between diet and boy
55 that's in companies sugar daddy so so
you think a guy works to 55 to get a
housewife
and in return
he wants her to go shopping and his
Range Rover and gets nothing in return
because I didn't hear anything you do
for him well he would he would get me as
his wife okay so you're telling me a guy
that worked he made it to 55 worked his
whole life busted like these men have
hard jobs they bust their ass to get
there okay most men aren't gonna make
that right yeah and in return
he he gets sex that he could get from
any [__] well and he gets a trophy wife
in it like he gets a wife that he can
say look my wife's sexy Circa tuned in
um zerka's been on the channel friend of
the show Pearl reads studies and offends
you with the studies these aren't these
are not her opinions you are mad at the
studies that remind you of your future
being like everyone else in the west a
disaster yeah that's true
um you know women that have slept with
more than five men have a very low
marital satisfaction rate it is what it
is and you know
um
really the odds are not for us the women
of the West the odds are against us even
if they don't have that the the media is
against them all marketing does and guys
you could you could I could sell you a
dream and tell you the future's bright
but right now it's not I I hope it
changes
um but I really don't see it happening
until they switch this system and we
stop having people role play and pretend
I think we need to get the government
out of marriage it needs to go just to
religious institutions who need to vet
people very thoroughly before giving
them like really guys
you know marriage marriage is a gift
and it's not deserved it's given to us
by God and if you don't follow God like
it I just think it makes a mockery out
of the whole thing I think it's really
offensive
yeah and this is and it all connects
guys everything connects the legal
system connects the marriage system
connects
um to the way men and women interact
today
um feminists have ruined a lot but let
me know what you guys think in the
comments uh maybe Pearl's just a crazy
old lady you know old old Pearl just
working so hard tweeting just tweet
tweet tweet
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time